welcome back to las vegas now it's a
wonderful time to head to area 15 where
you can celebrate the holidays with a
little twist a little weird twist until
january 3rd
allow me to show you around the place
[Music]
we have entered wonderland here at area
15. this is a great place
to celebrate the holidays christmas
director of cool stuff here
absolutely at night especially when the
lights are off all the trees are
flashing
music's pumping and you got your holiday
spirit but with a twist
every so often you might see our kind of
an elf
is a good example yes instead of elves
here area 15 they have aliens and they
look
really happy to be here yeah don't be
confused by the deadpan look that's a
she's jumping for joy right now they
just don't have the same
level of excitement here's an art car
called mr fusion
by the artist henry chang we have a
couple of these around this is our
version of the sleigh
uh you know santa sleigh but it's got a
fusion motor
to really get that extra speed that you
need especially nowadays
yeah of course this is an instagramable
moment right absolutely lots of
instagramable moments with
rudolph the red-nosed alien and all
around
inside the snow globes you can go in and
uh
kind of create your own version of a
postcard moment
here's a good one here oh i love it oh
snow globe this is so perfect especially
as we have to social distance we get our
own little bubble
you get your own bubble and this is kind
of the party bubble it looks like
they've been partying all night actually
let's go hang out let's go hang out with
these guys they probably need a little
pep talk
yeah they look like they had way too
much fun yet don't worry you'll get a
second win
stay in there stick in stick in there
buddy oh man okay
so area 15 hot for the holidays how can
people celebrate with you guys well you
go to area 15.com
20 tickets spread out but order your
tickets and uh come join us here
i love it well i'm having the time of
our life i'm trying to be on their level
so let's go ahead and take a selfie
let's do it let's take our selfie right
now